welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Fear The Walking Dead full series recap
it's the first of The Walking Dead
spin-off shows whose premise was to show
the zombie apocalypse as it happened you
know the fun part that Rick crimes slept
through our Story begins in Los Angeles
where we follow the Clark family led by
Madison Clark a no-nonsense mom who's a
high school guidance counselor her
boyfriend is the English teacher Travis
Manis and these two have been happily
dating for a bit after Madison's first
husband's death she has two kids from
her first marriage her daughter Alicia
likes art and boys but her son Nick is a
troubled kid who's become a drug addict
and in fact he's one of the first people
to see a zombie reports come in of this
new virus so in this show they call the
zombies infected most people don't
understand that these infected are The
Walking Dead But the Clark family
luckily is quick on the uptake Travis
went out to find his ex-wife and Son
Chris who was at the riots in downtown
as things escalate they seek shelter at
a local barber shop run by Daniel
Salazar but as things escalate even more
they all flee downtown for the relative
safety of the Clark house turns out the
Clark house is very safe because pretty
soon the military rolls up their
neighborhood is strategically located so
the military is making it their home
base safe Zone and so the Clarks got
really lucky the first week of the
zombie apocalypse they're basically
chilling the Salazar are still chilling
with them Travis is like yeah they're my
cousins but Daniel's wife broke her
ankle and anyone who's remotely injured
they're taken away including Nick who's
got a fever from withdrawal the
military's like don't worry they're fine
but Daniel Salazar lived through the
Civil War in El Salvador he knows
something's up so as his daughter ofilia
befriends one of the soldiers Daniel
kidnaps him and turns out he has a very
dark past he was the professional
torture guy yeah it seems like he's
escalating a bit too quickly but he does
learn that they're losing Los Angeles
and on their way out to try to stop the
spread they're going to kill this whole
neighborhood over at the holding cells
Nick meets Victor strand an apparently
rich guy who's a smooth talking con man
that befriends Nick as a potential ally
so as the base gets overrun Nick and
strand Escape while the rest of the crew
comes in to save them and they all fight
their way out but oh no Travis's ex-wife
got bit and it's the classic zombie
apocalypse thing he's got to put her
down now Los Angeles is lost but Victor
strand is a house in the Hills complete
with a yacht so in season two as the
military bombs Los Angeles as a Las
Stitch effort to stop the spread the
Clark family and friends take to the sea
on a luxury yacht the Abigail uh yeah
once again they got real lucky a lot of
people at Sea are not so lucky Alicia is
like we got to help them but Victor
strands like sorry boats full one day on
the radio Alicia meets a hot boy and
tells them where the boat is cuz he and
his friends need their help but of
course it was a trap they take Alicia
back to their base at the harbor and are
going to kill the rest of her friends
but this crew's messing with the wrong
people and immediately they break free
they negotiate the hostage exchange
Unfortunately they killed their hostage
but the good thing about the zombie
apocalypse dead people are still able to
walk around so our crew disembarks as
they make it to their destination Victor
strand's Villa in Mexico yeah these
Clarks got real lucky now it's actually
Victor's boyfriend's house and
unfortunately he just got bit don't no
it's his mom SL housekeeper who's in
charge here now and she's doing the
thing that hersel did where she doesn't
believe the zombies are really dead so
when Victor shoots his boyfriend to stop
him from turning she's real mad going to
kick Victor and the Clark family out but
Madison Clark will do whatever it takes
to protect her family so she brings this
woman down to The Cellar and locks her
up with the zombies but there's another
problem when Travis's son Chris is
standing over their bed with a knife
yeah ever since his mother's death he's
become kind of deranged and he's not the
only one who's going crazy Daniel
Salazar starts hallucinating his wife
who didn't make it and for some reason
he decides to burn the Villa down so as
the Clarks are heading out Nick is like
youro Mom this has kind of been a lot of
family time I'm at that age where I need
to strike out on my own oh kids they
grow up so fast now early on Nick
discovered if you cover yourself in the
zombie blood so you smell like the dead
they won't attack you so now Nick walks
around with the dead for protection yeah
he's ahead of the curve on the
whisperers pretty soon he's found by
Luciana who takes Nick back to her
Colonia which is a nice repl Nick loves
it here and Nick and Luciana get it on
the rest of the crew comes to a fancy
Beach Resort where they broke her a
piece between the hotel guests and the
hotel staff working together they make a
plan to lure all the zombies out and now
it's a really nice place to ride out the
zombie apocalypse the Clarks have locked
out once again but anyone in the area
who needs supplies has to shop at the
cartel Supermarket Madison over hears
her son Nick was here so she turns on
the lights at the hotel hoping he'll
find his way home unfortunately that
attracts everyone in the area not
including Nick but including Travis He
and Chris went off on their own on a
father-son apocalypse road trip but soon
they're joined by these douchebag frat
boy Spring Breakers and when they stop
at a farm Chris shoots this farmer no
mercy oh he's lost Travis is trying to
get through to his son but Chris is like
yo dad this has been a lot of family
time I think I need to go off on my own
all kids they grow up so fast pretty
soon those fat boys come to the hotel
too where apparently they were in a big
crash and no Chris died but Travis
realizes their story didn't add up and
he figures out that Chris survived the
crash but because he broke his leg he
was dead weight and they killed him so
Travis goes berser can murders these
guys with his bare hands after this the
Clarks are kicked out of the hotel they
go to Nick's Colonia which is overrun
after a fight with the cartel Nick is
leading his new Mexican family across
the border for hopefully a better life
in America but turns out the Border
still guarded Nick and Luciana captured
so in season 3 Madison follows Nick
across the border where she and Alicia
are given the warm welcome by this nice
guy Troy but he's not so nice to the
brown people in the group where he's
killing them running experiments to see
how long it takes them to turn soon
Madison figures him out and attacks him
oh spoon to the eye Madison Clark
hardcore War but just then another guy
shows up like whoa sorry that's my crazy
brother just let him go and we'll sort
this all out turns out they're not the
military they're from a ranch nearby and
most of them are good people sorry about
Troy and when zombies show up they end
up separated Travis takes the helicopter
but the helicopter is not the safer
option someone shoots at it and Travis
gets hit oh Travis just when you were
getting cool so the Clarks arrive at the
ranch run by old man Jeremiah aotto and
this Ranch is a great place to be it's a
doomsday prepper community so it's
incredibly well prepared Madison's like
yo we're going to make this our home and
if we don't like how they're running
things we'll just take it over the good
brother Jake is on their side because he
and Alicia immediately start dating but
Troy's a different story he's definitely
a bit of a psychopath but in the zombie
apocalypse maybe a psychopath is exactly
who you want on your side Madison the
guidance counselor knows how to get
through to this kid starts becoming his
like mother figure Nick of course wants
to kill him but Nick's a little bit
crazy too and these two become best
friends Luciana is still here but the
people at the ranch really don't like
Mexicans so she decides to leave the
show for now so as the ranch is
searching for who shot at the helicopter
they come across one of their Scouts out
and it's an incredibly memorable
disturbing scene as he's still talking
cuz the Raven's picking at his brain and
so we meet kataka leader of the Native
American reservation who wants the
ranchers to leave cuz they're on our
land so in this war because the Clarks
are living at the ranch they deao find
themselves on the ranch's side but it
becomes apparent kataka is the good guy
before the zombie apocalypse Jeremiah
Otto murdered his father and got away
with it so Alicia The Optimist tries to
make peace and who does she find here
but opilia Salazar she ended up crossing
the border to and was taken in by kataka
they negotiate the hostage deal where
ailia goes to the ranch but the next
morning all the guards get sick oh she
poison their coffee with her kids in
danger Madison Clark's ready to end this
war and so she kills Jeremiah Otto well
technically it was Nick who pulled the
trigger and so there's peace for the new
generation all going to live at the
ranch together but even if they can all
get along it's not going to work because
the ranch is almost out of water so they
go to El Bazar at the old football
stadium a lawless place where you can
buy anything Nick and Troy have a wild
Knight getting high on zombie brain
stems and who do they find here but
Victor strand who's got a lead on a ton
of water all the water in this region
comes from the dam and Victor strand is
friends with the owner well not friends
so much as someone he wants con but
turns out one of this gu guards is
Daniel Salazar yes he survived the Villa
fire and ended up befriending the water
resistance when this guy finds out
Daniel was a death squad killer he
recruits him for security but Daniel
kills this guy in sides with the water
Queen who's Distributing water more
fairly to the people so as Madison's
negotiating a deal for the water there's
trouble back at the ranch cuz a zombie
horde is coming right to it yes Troy did
not accept the piece between the ranch
and the reservation so he's luring this
horde here to destroy the whole thing
it's a big old zombie fight but the
ranch is destroyed and Alicia is the
sole survivor but unfortunately opilia
was bit and as Daniel's about to be
reunited with his daughter he's minutes
late to say goodbye meanwhile Madison
finally learns it was Troy who led the
zombies to the ranch and it's a tragic
situation as Troy kind of wants to be a
good boy for his new mother figure
Madison realizes he's too much of a
Loose Cannon and know she kills him but
things are looking up for Madison Clark
who's got a new safe home here at the
dam unfortunately the motorcycle gang
that runs the bizar the Proctors is
comeing to take it right now and they
have an inside man cuz Victor strand cut
a deal with him and as he and Daniel
fight it out oh he shoots Daniel in the
face it goes through though so he's okay
so as proor John takes the dam Victor's
deal was for him in the Clark safety but
for some reason that deal's off but Nick
has the Detonator to blow the whole
thing up yeah New Deal my family goes
free and now Nick decides screw it yes
he blows up the damn freeze the river to
the people and so after a pretty great
third season Fear The Walking Dead is
finally hitting its stride I'm excited
for what new adventures await the Clark
family in this interesting meic Cali
region but in season 4 the show has a
soft reboot with a new main character
Morgan Jones crossing over from the main
show when Rick gmes met him in season
one he was a normal guy but in season
three when his wife and son died he went
crazy and started killing everyone later
he made a friend who taught him the art
of Peace so now he doesn't kill anyone
but he had to kill during the Savior war
and he took it too far started killing
everyone so now Morgan's living by
himself in the dump he's like yo Rick I
got to leave the group and go find
myself and so he pulls a Forest Gump and
just starts running runs himself all the
way to Texas his first friend here is
John Dory a real life cowboy who was a
professional trick shot artist they
befriend Al who's got this big SWAT
truck with epic guns built in she was a
reporter and is still going around
filming people getting the scoop on the
zombie apocalypse they find someone who
needs help and it is Alicia Clark but oh
it's a trap yes our old crew ambushes
this new one but very quickly they turn
it around and Al interviews them to find
out how they ended up this way after
Mexico the Clark family made it to Texas
where they settled in an old baseball
stadium things were great for a while
Luciana came back without explanation
but one night a group arrived and
menacingly just sat there they're called
the vultures cuz they don't attack they
just wait for settlements to fail then
scavenge The Remains and indeed the
stadium is falling cuz they got weevils
in their crops our group manages to find
some new seeds and replant but then the
vultures busting a bunch of zombies and
oh the Stadium's overrun Madison's kids
are stuck outside the walls and so she
lights a flare and lurs all the zombies
inside then locks the gate to the
stadium and sets it on fire sacrificing
herself to save her kids so in the
present Nick finds one of the vultures
Morgan tries to stop him hey killing's
bad but Nick doesn't listen kills this
guy but then immediately Nick is shot oh
by Charlie the little girl who's with
the vultures and the cycle of violence
continues so Nick Clark one of the best
most complex characters in The Walking
Dead Universe gets a tear-jerking death
so the group hunts down the rest of the
vultures but one of them is this woman
June who turns out was John dory's
girlfriend he was living a lonely life
in his cabin but one day he met June and
they fell in love but then she was
scared and ran off so Alicia wants to
kill her but Morgan's not going to let
that happen gives her the speech killing
is bad and turns out Al had interviewed
Madison when they were separated earlier
I guess she talked about how she hoped
her kids wouldn't lose themselves in the
zombie apocalypse and so it gets through
to Alicia and we're all friends now
Morgan's not planning to stick around
he's going to go back to Virginia but on
the way at a rest stop he meets a couple
truckers Sarah and Wendell and they're
still cruising the highways helping
people by dropping off Supply boxes take
which you need leave which don't turns
out though they just stole this truck
from the guy who was really doing it
polar bear but Morgan convinces them to
change their ways and now they're going
around doing it for real pretty soon
they recruit the rest of the group so
Morgan and friends have a new mission
their Texas trucker helper people now
Texas is a big place so at this point
the show becomes mostly just characters
talking to each other over the walkie
and the show becomes a huge snoozefest
as nothing really happens except when
weird stuff happens but honestly I
stopped paying attention at one point
there's a massive hurricane and Alicia
takes shelter with the vulture girl
Charlie but she's been infected with
Morgan's no killing so she doesn't get
revenge for her brother and instead
these two become best friends and if
you're wondering what the heck Alicia's
holding at a water park she found a
machine gun but then the case came off
she Sharp that into a point and it's
become her new signature zombie killing
weapon the main villain of this part of
the show is this random dirty hobo lady
who's mad I guess that our group's
trying to help people she starts
sabotaging them and our group can't just
kill her cuz they don't kill people the
big climax is when she poisons them but
earlier they met a brewer he ended up
dying but Morgan brings in the auggies
Ale Beer truck and turns out beer is the
cure for poison June is a nurse so it's
medically sound so the day is saved and
our group's free to keep driving around
Texas talking on walkies and helping
people so in season five our group gets
a call for help from the other side of
Texas and apparently they can't drive
there cuz the roads are out so they fly
a plane while they crash a plane but
don't worry they're fine we're here to
help but turns out it was a fake call
from this other trucker Logan who was
polar bear's old partner and used to
live here and came up with an excuse to
get them all out so half our group
stranded on the other side of Texas and
there's someone here who's marking their
territory by stringing zombies together
turns out it is a feral group of kids
but Morgan gives them a talking two and
our group adopts a bunch of children
while they're working to fix their plane
John and June go to the old western town
where he worked as a gunslinger and here
they meet Dwight crossing over from The
Walking Dead remember he was one of
negan's top guys but he switched sides
to help our group he's looking for his
wife Sherry who ran away from Negan but
left him the Clue the beer and Pretzel's
forever honeymoon and he's followed her
Trail all the way to Texas but now he's
trapped and there's two zombies left and
John dory's only got one bullet so he
has Dwight hold up the axe for the trick
shot the San Antonio split wow splits
the bullet then rejoining the show is
Daniel Salazar who's pretty mad at
strand for shooting him in the face but
he forgives him he's a nice old man now
who's adopted a cat skidmark strand
wants to borrow his plane to rescue
their friends but the plane breaks but
strand finds another flying vehicle yes
the Auggie Zale hot air balloon F shows
gone off the rails but something
important happens for The Wider Walking
Dead universe as Alia finds a soldier
from the Civic Republic military yes the
mysterious super group with the three-
ring logos that has the helicopters that
took rck crimes Al is captured by one of
their soldiers and they're real serious
supposed to shoot people on site but her
helicopter's out of fuel so she needs
Al's help to climb the mountain and get
more and now they've bonded so she
breaks protocol instead of killing her
they start making out but the big
problem on this side of Texas is
radiation as the scientist Grace
explains the nuclear power plant is
melting down so they fix the plane just
on time to escape the nuclear apocalypse
for now so back on the good side of
Texas we've got a found footage thing
going on as our group's filming a
documentary on how they're helping
people and leaving it in VCRs at rest
stops I guess they make some new friends
like this random Rabbi and this guy Wes
who's been painting trees and inspired
fires Alicia to paint trees too but
driving around Texas takes a lot of gas
and it seems like our crew has an
infinite Supply turns out they found an
oil refinery called tank town and
they're using zombie power to drill for
oil cool but remember Logan he's still
around and now his crew comes to take it
but what's this they're all killed by a
bigger group who ride around on horses
led by red-haired Virginia she and her
Rangers are consolidating Texas under
her Rule and our groups all invited to
join the problem is she doesn't help
everyone she only accepts people who add
value to the group so Morgan rejects her
we're going to keep doing things our way
and so she makes her own documentary and
for a while we got waren documentaries
this one dude in Morgan's group is so
dedicated he keeps filming when the
bridge collapses and has the dumbest
death in The Walking Dead Virginia did
take tank Town though and so with their
group out of gas they're walking to
another Community but it's all overrun
with zombies so they have to give up all
right Virginia we'll join you but then
they realize they can just lure the
zombies out of there and they fix up
this town and John and June get married
but Virginia was already on her way so
she crashes the wedding and now joining
her is not not optional just to be mean
she separates our whole group sending
them off to her different communities
but Morgan Jones is staying here he's a
leader that could undermine her rule so
she's got to kill him but before she can
finish him off she gets a call that
Grace is pregnant yes all season she
thought she was dying of radiation
poisoning but turns out pregnancy has
the same symptoms and Morgan and Grace
have fallen in love but actually the
baby's not his that was from the other
guy she was dating before anyway now
that he's going to be kind of a father
Virginia doesn't kill him and leaves him
there to bleed out but in season six
Morgan does not bleed out he meets a new
friend who has a safe place to live
behind a dam yeah the lake is dried up
so there's a whole Hidden Valley here
but now a cool axe wielding bounty
hunters after Morgan Virginia sent him
to finish the job and he's not scared of
Morgan because he watched the
documentary about how he doesn't kill
people and so to stop this guy Morgan
has to kill again he attaches this guy's
axe to his staff to represent that now
he can kill when he has to so Morgan
resolves to build a new community here
and Rescue all his friends from the
villainous Virginia of course virgin is
not a bad villain in most of her
settlements life is pretty good but
undesirables are put on zombie killing
Duty and when they're overrun to save
himself strand injures this guy and
throws him to The Horde and for his
Ingenuity strand is promoted Virginia
makes him one of her Rangers Al and
Dwight are sent out scouting and who
does Dwight finally find but his long
lost wife Sherry oh forever honeymoon
reunited but she's made friends with the
Virginia resistance group of people that
she cast out so Dwight joins them and
they do a Big Heist to get the SWAT
truck back now we meet Virginia's little
sister Dakota who wants to join our
group because she thinks her sister is
evil but John dor was investigating a
murder coverup and turns out Dakota was
the killer she's a messed up little kid
and now in fact she shoots John Dory
what his nurse wife June is here to help
but oh she's too late John Dory dies but
now Virginia wants her sister back so
she's going to execute our group if
Morgan doesn't return her she wants
strand to pull the trigger to prove his
loyalty but Victor strand has used his
smooth tuck and skills to get half the
Rangers on his side oh it's a coup
against Virginia blam blam blam so
Morgan offers Virginia Asylum everyone
else wants her executed but Morgan
doesn't kill her he dramatically thrusts
his axe into the ground no more killing
anymore again but June blames Virginia
for John Do's death and she kills her oh
and now June's banished from the group
but the rest of our group is all
together again living happily in
Morgan's Hidden Valley and if they start
raising horses they can call it Morgan's
Hidden Valley Ranch but a new bad group
starts sabotaging them and they like to
Graffiti the end is the beginning
they're a doomsday cult living in a
bunker and their leader is the the
charismatic weirdo Teddy meanwhile June
found a random old man who turns out is
none other than John Dory senior and
Teddy is the serial killer that he was
hunting when he was a cop wow Texas is a
really small world and they found a
beach to nuclear submarine so Teddy's
plan is to Nuke G of Texas and end the
world even more so Morgan and strand
busting to stop them but they're overrun
strand's like hey Morgan you're willing
to sacrifice yourself to save the world
right cuz I'm not and he pushes Morgan
into the zombie zombies to save himself
but Morgan survives so now things
between them are awkward but they're
still too late Teddy launches the
missiles Dakota by the way had joined
Teddy but long story short now she
realizes he's a fraud so she kills him
but the nuke's already launched so yes
it's happening boom nuclear apocalypse
Texas time magically our group all
somehow found bunkers Alicia in fact was
put in Teddy's main one in fact most of
our gang was picked up by a helicopter
yeah Al called her Civic Republic
girlfriend to give him a lift they don't
fly too the Civ Republic though she just
drops them outside the blast radius and
pretty soon after Al leaves the group to
live happily ever after with her
helicopter girlfriend Morgan and Grace
did not find a bunker uh they just hit
under a truck which I guess works and by
the way yeah they've got a baby but it's
not Grace's baby hers didn't make it
it's another random baby who they named
Morgan and named Morgan The Godfather
Victor strand didn't find a bunker he
found an apartment so he figured this
was the end but this building turns out
to be just outside the blast radius and
Victor strand now believes he's on the
right path so in season 7 it's the
nuclear Apocalypse in the zombie
apocalypse and everyone's adjusted
really quick managed to make radiation
suits and stuff but they can't leave
Texas because of where the bombs dropped
it's Penning them in they're all stuck
here but right in the middle is the safe
zone of Victor strand's Tower strand has
adopted a new style now dressing in
dictator Chic and he's become a dictator
making the hard choices to keep this
place safe executing anyone who doesn't
support it but he only lets in those
with useful skills even half our old
group he sends some packing and Morgan
especially he doesn't want in after
their awkwardness on the subl season but
he does accept Baby Mo and and sort of
keeps her as a hostage Alicia was in
Teddy's bunker but with Teddy dead she
kind of takes over now this was a real
government bunker where a senator was
hiding before he died but she befriends
his Aid who's still alive and he has
Files about a safe place Padre more on
that later but now tragically Alicia is
bit she amputates her arm but she was
too late she still got the zombie fever
it seems to be slowed down though she's
okay for a while so she straps her arm
bone back on to herself and makes it her
new signature weapon now strand likes
Alicia he's going to let her in but when
she finds out he killed her senator's
Aid boyfriend she's like you become the
villain Victor This Means War but they
can't attack the Tower with Baby Mo
inside so it's John Dory Senor who suits
up in armor to get her out of there and
sacrifices himself so Alicia leads the
group in an assault on the tower Wes had
joined team strand but now he betrays
him to take over so strand kills Wes to
save Alicia then in Alicia and strand's
final fight they burn the tower down so
no one gets it and so with nowhere safe
left in Texas the rest of our group
takes to the Sea Alicia hallucinates a
bird which makes her realize she
forgives Strand and sends him off to
join him while she stays behind to die
of zombie fever except she doesn't
though I guess she's fine now Morgan
made it to Louisiana and who does he
meet here but Madison Clark after all
this time they brought her back she
survived the stadium fire but inhaled a
lot of smoke so now she needs an oxygen
tank and she's picked up a new signature
weapon a gigantic sledg Hammer but now
she kidnaps little mo yeah she's working
as a baby snatcher for a group called
Padre but when Morgan tells her he was
friends with her kids although I'm sorry
to say they're both dead now but now
she's willing to turn on Padre and help
him get his daughter back so in season 8
Padre is on a h hidden island that was
originally a military safe Zone and they
are successfully keeping kids safe but
they're kind of brainwashing them you
don't need your parents you just need
Padre now Padre himself hides behind
two-way glass and only communicates over
the speaker Morgan and Madison try to
rescue Mo but it seems like they failed
Madison's captured this one girl finds
Madison and helps her Escape but soon
Madison realizes this is Baby Mo it's
been a seven-year time Jump to catch up
with The Walking Dead Prime so Madison
helps Mo escape again but when they find
Morgan he's working for Padre yeah he
and Grace decided that Padre could keep
Mo safer than they could and so have let
her grow up without them in her life but
this woman shrike is the Padre leader
who's not behind the glass and she can't
risk Mo meeting her parents again so she
tries to kill Morgan he's got to escape
Dwight and Sherry have been working for
Padre too they took the same deal cuz
they have a son now but now they bring
him to June cuz he needs medical
attention but June had left Padre
because they were making her do
experiments having people bit on purpose
and Blasting them with radiation
inspired by how Alicia survived so long
they think radiation might be the key to
the zombie cure and now shrike captures
them all and with the zombie head
mounted on the crane arm has their son
bit so Jun will have to resume the
experiments in hopes to save his life
but now shrikes captured by the Padre
resistance of disgruntled parents who
have been formed into a gorilla Commando
crew by Captain Daniel Salazar by the
way his main plot in season six and
seven was that he's old now he's got
dementia but he's been drinking gko te
and so he's cured now so they break the
glass to meet the real Padre who turns
out is shri's brother their father was
the original Padre Commander but when he
died in front of them they were real sad
and they decided that kids are better
without their parents so they don't have
to be sad when their parents die
meanwhile Morgan and family have gotten
away they've got all the way to Atlanta
to his house from season 1 when he met
Rick crimes he wanted to face his demons
and lay to rest his wife and son so that
he and his new family can live happily
ever after but just then oh no it's a
zombie attack and Grace is bit so they
boat all the way back to Padre in the
hopes the radiation cure can heal her
because it seemed to work on Dwight
Sherry son but it doesn't last it just
slowed it down a little and he does die
so Grace has her tearful farewell with
Morgan in the style of the show over the
walkie but now Morgan starts writing
clear on the wall again yeah he goes
crazy like Walking Dead season 3 when
he's blacking out and trying to kill
everyone but soon he gets himself under
control and in the final showdown with
podre he gives the big speech and the
Power of Love wins the day except for
shrike who was awful and June kills her
now it's time for Morgan to say goodbye
he's going back this time to actually
meet up with his original Walking Dead
friends he tries to call his old friend
Rick Grimes hey man if you're out there
I'm coming to find you and so Morgan
Jones with his daughter Morgan set off
on another adventure Madison Clark is
staying by behind going to turn Padre
into a good place but now we catch up
with Victor strand who's inexplicably
speaking German with a new hot boyfriend
and adopted son but now Madison Clark
has tracked him down yes old best
friends reunited but a new bad group has
followed her here led by none other than
Troy Auto yeah they're bringing everyone
back yeah he survived Madison's Hammer
to the head and now he's here for
revenge and to take over Padre and his
revenge on Madison has already begun
because CU he killed Alicia to take down
Troy they need some more allies so they
find Luciana who's still trucking around
taking up polar bear's old mantle
working with her is Charlie who survived
the radiation and Madison finally learns
she's the one who killed Nick but Troy
takes her hostage going to trade her for
Padre's location but Charlie breaks free
and to make up for Nick and save Padre
she no kills herself but then our crew
takes a kid prisoner it's this girl
Tracy who is Troy's daughter and she's
like Madison you killed my mom wait what
I didn't know your mom turns out to Le
rescued them and inspired Troy's wife to
try to help people which got her killed
and because Madison was the one who told
Alicia to help people Troy blames
Madison but now Madison and Troy are
captured by the Padre brother they got
to work together to escape across this
bridge which obviously is not a good
escape plan but now they've had a heart
tohe heart Troy's like I'm sorry let's
be friends but Madison oh doesn't
forgive him she kills him again but now
Troy drops a new truth bomb Tracy isn't
his daughter it's Alicia's daughter who
he kidnapped so now Madison wants to
protect her granddaughter daughter but
it's like yo you just killed my dad and
she shoots her and now to avenge Troy
his gang wrangled up a zombie horde and
Unleashed it at Padre so things look
Bleak our crew surrounded but Madison
Clark survived the bullet hit Alicia's
lucky necklace so Madison Clark runs
over there and does what she does best
leads all the zombies inside so all the
people can escape and lights the whole
place on fire everyone assumes she's
dead for real this time except she's not
Tracy pulled her out of the rubble and
now coming to join them is Alicia who's
also alive Troy stabbed her but she
recovered and now mother and daughter
are reunited Madison's excited to be a
grandma but Alicia's like I don't have a
kid Troy knows Madison protects her own
family so he lied about that so she
would protect her so now they go to
check on their friends who are back to
their old ways Trucking around but now
in honor of Madison's sacrifice they've
renamed Padre to Madre but Padre is a
smoking ruins so our crew has no home
base Dwight has an idea to go back to
the sanctuary yeah negan's old for
Fortress he randomly went back there
earlier this season and took out the new
gang that was living inside he's like we
should take it and make it a good place
so he and Sherry are going to try that
the rest of the group is splitting up
for now just hanging with their closest
loved ones but as str's heading off with
his new German family he sees the Clark
girls in the rearview mirror and it's a
tearful farewell as he realizes what
they're doing their deaths have inspired
the group more than their lives would
and they decide they're going to go to
check out their old home of Los Angeles
and that's where Fear The Walking Dead
come comes to an end if you like this
recap hit that subscribe button for more
of the best Recaps of TV and
movies